Well, hello everybody and welcome to another Zoom call.
Take your questions and leave the best to answer them.
Get a reminder to look at our member site for any new information.
And I do information as of several weeks ago.
It's been that you've been self-scheduled now through our members website
or our regular member website for appointments.
So it's really easy to do.
You'll see a little button that looks like this.
And you can easily click on the self-schedule button and schedule yourself.
For follow-up visits, we also reduced the fee for follow-up visits $135.
And please fill out the follow-up coaching window for a call so we kind of have up.
Read to what we're going to be talking about.
So feel free to pre-schedule, re-schedule, visit with me at any time.
You want to go over labs.
Also, if we're going to go over labs, please choose when you hit that schedule on button.
It'll give you an option to schedule a Zoom call.
And if we're going to go over labs, it may be better if we do it on a Zoom call
because then I can hear my screen similar as to what I'm doing right now.
And it'd be able to show you the lab.
It's a lot easier to say, you know, you look at a page two and fill.
So it's a little bit easier that way.
So you can self-schedule.
And again, if you're going to do labs, go in over labs.
Send in labs or anything like that.
If you want to go over that, it might be good to do a Zoom call.
Remember, also, you have access to all of our courses and all our blog posts.
So all right.
I've been using my new right machine for a week now, no matter how much time is indicated for each night's session.
The bulb is always active lights on some noise and hot temperature of bomb for 10 hours,
rather than what is listed on each night's page.
It's normal.
Yes, it does.
So if you have the computer open after you hit run.
Often the frequencies will feed back to the computer and affect that timer.
That timer as it's tiny down could be inaccurate.
That's why we suggest that you once you hit run, you close the computer.
If you have the computer, go to sleep.
You'll have less chance of it feeding back to that and stayed on longer or getting stuck in the last frequency.
We've had issues in the past where sometimes people will say,
like, revs only supposed to be eight hours.
And I got up in the morning and left with it still on.
And I came home and it was on all day long.
I was going on, well, if you left the computer open, usually that's the reason.
Because the frequencies, these are frequencies and they affect electronics sometimes.
So it could have been back to that person said I do close the computer, but sometimes that right away.
So it could have just been back to that.
So just close the computer.
Time where it says on there and says eight hours, that's not always correct.
So you could just ignore that.
If it's staying on for like 15 hours or something, it's just getting stuck on the last frequency.
There's no harmonics.
It can't work anything.
That's why when you wake up in the morning, I suggest you to flip the awk switch on the right machine itself just to turn it off.
Allow it to cool.
That would be the only harm in it stayed on 24 seven isn't would get hot.
But if you have air circulating around the machine, that isn't really an issue at all either.
We do have multiple patients that are running at 24 seven.
We have some people in the hospital.
And since they're late in the hospital, but all day there, they've been running the right 24 seven.
There's no harm in that.
The only harm would be as if you don't have proper, you don't have proper circulation.
And it's just that machine itself is heated up.
There isn't any harm in the ball, unless you actually have the bulb like.
You know, wrapped in a blanket or something, it's not getting any air.
And that could heat up and damage the plastic a little bit on the outside.
Otherwise, there isn't any problem with that.
Have you seen an increase in cancer sense to COVID vaccine?
I think cancer rates since the COVID vaccine.
Well, it's dangerous question to ask without the.
Cancels, but you know, we have had comments from people.
I think we actually just spoke to a person.
A couple of weeks ago that said that.
This person and their eight siblings had to get vaccinated in order to see their dying mother.
In in hospice.
And within a year, all eight siblings have a diagnosis cancer.
That's great dramatic.
You know, spoken to people in the fold with these kind of comments.
That had not, you know, their cancer was in remission.
They got the vaccine. The cancer came back with a vengeance right after the vaccine.
The vaccine does, you know, have an immune suppression component to it that can cause that.
There can be other physiological causes to that.
You went to Google and you searched.
Has there been an increased cancer rate sense of vaccine?
You get the exact opposite response.
But Google has been filtered and anything that shows any studies that have shown different than that have been.
Taken off of Google.
I've seen multiple studies from Europe that showed that there is increased cancer rate.
A people that have been vaccinated increase cancer growth on people that have been vaccinated.
But you won't find any of those out of Google because Google is a branch of the of the pharmaceutical propaganda arm.
So it is you won't see that on that.
So we have seen it increase.
And I don't know the complete physiology of that.
I've never been rolled back seat of any kind, certainly not that one.
Why would somebody with cancer have anemia?
So in anemia, there's different types of anemia.
So you could have anemia due to blood loss.
You can see that in a person with cancer.
If the person has, especially if they have a cancer in the intestinal tract and they're having bleeding, then they have blood loss.
Or you have a vaginal cancer or uterine cancer where you have blood loss.
You can have anemia due to a loss of blood.
So let's say a person doesn't have cancer and they go in for a regular physical.
And they have low red blood cell come to some other signs of anemia, the red cell width and things like that.
The first thing that doctors should do is try to investigate what is the cause of this anemia.
But if a person already has a diagnosis of cancer.
And now they're, he will go, but it is going down to their red blood cell count is going down the red cell, which is going up.
Things like that other signs of anemia of chronic disease.
That's a different type of anemia.
So anemia of chronic disease is actually the name of a type of anemia.
That's very often very common in cancer, especially later stage cancer.
It's common for a couple of reasons.
Number one, if the person is doing chemotherapy, chemotherapy can affect red blood cell production and cause anemia of chronic disease.
If the person is not doing chemotherapy, another reason why you can get anemia of chronic disease with cancer
is because of a general state of inflammation, inflammation, especially that affects red blood cell production is not uncommon.
And that can be a cause.
Another cause can be the cancer is godly up iron iron can be a fuel source for cancer that can be one of the issues.
And that is kind of a becomes problematic because typically if a person has iron deficiency, anemia what has to do with blood loss, you give the person iron.
And you can't give the person or you have to be careful, give me the cancer patient iron because it can be feeding the cancer.
So that's why you would always use that iron or an artimistic program call if you're going to do that to you to add artimistic with the iron if you do want to supplement iron.
Another side note of this, if a person has elevated ferritin, even if they have anemia, you can't give them iron.
So if you have elevated ferritin and you give iron, you're going to make the person worse elevated ferritin is a side of heavy inflammation and you have to be careful with that.
So there's multiple reasons why you get anemia with cancer, you have to investigate all of those.
We've had questions on this forum in the past multiple times whether a person should get a blood transfusion if they have anemia that's quite severe and the answer has been well typically they won't give you one.
Every hospital, every clinic has their has their cutoff range usually you have to be have a hemoglobin below 8.0 some of it some people some clinics it's below 7.5 summits you have to be down to 7.0 before they'll give you a transfusion.
And my answer is always yes I think it's in the best interest to get that can really help you feel better.
What is the best way to deal with constipation? Well again, like everything you want to find out why so one of the reasons why you have constipation is that you're not properly properly digesting, especially proteins.
So if you have mild constipation by first thing is to start taking some HCl and digestive enzyme.
So taking like our clear digest product would be a good one or any HCl and digestive enzyme product would be a good one, especially when you're you know you take that with your meals.
So you're always asking the question why you know all I just prone to constipation you know get more difficult moments and things.
Then also think about adding magnesium, especially right for bad taking some magnesium magnesium malate or magnesium glycinate or good magnesium sources to help with constipation.
What magnesium does is basically if you kind of a little bit over goes on magnesium before you go to bed, then magnesium will be dumped into the bowel and magnesium being ion will draw water.
So you can't be dehydrated or it won't work but if you're drinking plenty of water and you take a little bit too much magnesium.
You know harm in taking too much magnesium because you just dump it into the bowel any excess so you can't be injured by taking too much magnesium magnesium is a necessary co factor in about 500 different metabolic processes in your body.
So most people are deficient in magnesium you know if their diet isn't you know you know high and vegetables and such so magnesium is a good thing for everybody to be taking.
If you take too much magnesium you will again like I said dump it into the bowel and that will draw water and it will loosen your stools.
Now if you take even you know way too much magnesium you'll dump more into the bowel and it will loosen your stools even more so you just got to be careful with that because you can kind of have diarrhea the next day and well that's not pleasant so you have to kind of find the dose that's right for you.
If a person calls me and says i've done magnesium and magnesium has always worked for me but I've just been so concentrated I don't know what's wrong with me.
Then the thing to do is to use cape allo so cape allo is just it's a different type of allo is that allo barbaric sense it's not like an allo liquid allo that you would drink to help heal your gut cape allo is the type of allo that really causes you to have a good ballable but if you're really constipated.
Another product is cascara sagrada that is an herb that's liquid herb I don't have a picture of that here but that can be helpful personally I would first recommend the cape allo.
It just works it just works every time taking one or two before bed will really help you clean out.
Again, you know we talk about this we talk about detoxification the worst thing you've health wise for a person is they're not really getting their body cleaned out on a regular basis so.
If you're not really feeling like your empty empty your balls on a daily basis that could be a major major problem a question come in about the.
CV CV so what's let's talk about that in that question to think I got a question about blood.
That's the next one what are the most important blood tests to get and how often should I order them.
So I think anybody with a serious disease like cancer should get fairly regular.
CBC which is a complete blood count and CMP which is a complete metabolic profile on a fairly regular basis meaning that hints under your condition how regular that is if you have abnormalities in either of those tests you should do it you know at least monthly.
spoke to someone you know a few months ago and they had you know pretty strong abnormalities on their CBC and their complete metabolic panel and the test was done you know by their by their oncologist oncologist never went over the labs with the person.
I was sent to labs this was now I think five weeks post draw meeting after five weeks after that draw was done and you know done of them were reordered why why order in the first place if you're not looking at them to make some analysis of them.
And if certainly if the person has you know fairly distinct anemia you better be running them again you don't know sometimes you should be running them weekly so.
So it depends on what's going on the person has fairly severe anemia you should be really running them weekly maybe.
Maybe every two weeks but you need to be keeping an eye on your patient so.
I don't get it you see that very often with people that are working with a little college is the oncologist will order labs there's abnormalities on the labs and either they're not addressed at all or they're not reordering lab after maybe they're told you have anemia you should be on iron but.
If you look at them again I don't know so the complete wellness panel that you can order off of our site has a CVC with differential complete comprehensive metabolic profile and a bunch of other things that I think are beneficial.
So for somebody just to get a good wellness panel getting that run can be very helpful.
It depends on what's going on if you have cancer and you have shown two more markers positive in the past either doing a female tumor panel or a male tumor panel depending on your gender adding that to your protocol as well if you're especially a female and you're dealing with.
A hormone positive cancers then consider doing a Dutch profile a Dutch is a complete the Dutch complete is a good complete horrible profile though um that doesn't have to be done as often so.
This really needs to be done just as needed this wouldn't be something that you look at on a fairly regular basis if it was within normal limits that I would say maybe ever six months and you could even push it out to a year everything was normal your tumor markers it all depends on if you're using those to kind of guide your cancer care if those show up positive getting those done on a multi basis could be helpful.
But certainly the complete metabolic panel and the comprehensive or the CBC would be done on a more regular basis.
The question that came to me directly was recently a CBC results showed some markers like fairytale to be extremely high.
If I said you those CBC results with the cheek swab can you just add additional supplements or should I schedule a call.
You should probably schedule call send me those results now I have a software that I put all those results in that is really kind of cool and it gives you a really nice readout.
And more often than some of these things aren't being addressed so if fairytale is very high what is that usually indicate well that usually indicates some people think that fairytale is only an iron marker while fairytale can indicate iron levels and iron transport levels because that's how iron is transport transported.
Typically a fairytale is elevated it's an inflammatory marker so if fairytale is elevated and you're currently taking iron make sure that you stock taking iron so
send me those those and more and then schedule a talk that we should go over that right that question isn't that way.
Okay I'm scheduled for a follow up psm a scan next week to assess status of my prostate cancer I think I'm doing well with all the detox pathways.
But I was just wondering if there's anything special anything special I should do in advance of and following the psm a scan to detox the radiation die chemicals.
They use for contrast during the scan vitamin supplement extra sodas and everything with them so a pms a scan is a type of a pet scan.
But it's so usually on a pet scan you're drinking a glucose substance and then you're doing a pet scan and the pet scan is measuring the uptake of that glucose so highly metabolic areas that is cancerous sites will uptake the glucose more readily and it will show hotter on a pet scan a pet scan in itself.
So it involves radiation so if you're going to do a pet scan you're going to get rate you're going to have radiation.
Now just at a regular pet scan do you need to detoxify anything else no because you don't need to add anything to help detox the glucose the glucose solution you do need to add to help detox the radiation though so we'll talk about that now with the pms a scan it's different it's not just a regular scan but you're also
getting injected with a radioactive substance that targets a specific antigen on the cell membrane of cancer cells called the prostate specific antigen that's PSA but it's the membrane antigen which is a little bit different than just the PS the prostate specific antigen.
It's not that radioactive substance is attaching to that and it's a more specific than a pet scan for prostate cancer patients if you don't have prostate cancer you're not going to get a yes ma pet scan you'll get a regular pet scan.
So you have really extra radiation to detoxify now the positive about the scan it's going to be much more specific and it's going to be more detailed to make sure that there isn't spread prostate cancer the negative is you're going to get more radiation.
This is what it is so how do you detox that well you use homeopaths and you work on the detox pathways so everything you already are doing like you mentioned in your question you're really working on your detox pathways is there anything else to take it's the homeopaths these two this is our homeopaths for radium this is a homeopath from PHP for multiple different radiation things both of these really should be used.
So it just take them just exactly how it says to take them right on the label we put the instructions right at our label and there's instructions on PHP's label they're inexpensive little things to help you get rid of stuff homeopaths work so if you're taking doing a CT scan if you're doing a regular pet scan or you're doing a PSMA pet scan these are the two things that you would use.
If you're doing an MRI that's different an MRI is magnetic resident imaging that is not using radiation you do not need these two things however most MRIs are using a contrast eye and that contrast eye with most MRIs is gadolinium so gadolinium is a different thing so our MRI homeopath looks like this bottle here.
This one but it says MRI on it it's a different substance in there it's gadolinium homeopath so use that if you're going to do it MRI if you're doing an MRI with no contrast eye whether you don't need anything but if you're doing an MRI normal MRI that's using a contrast eye it's using gadolinium use the MRI gadolinium homeopath.
So with a pet scan use these homeopaths okay so I had the bilateral mastectomy and now I guess in revision.
Praise God is it pointless to research breast cancer now.
Should I research preventative measures for lung and bone cancer since that's where they come back to trusting God this will not occur.
I wouldn't research lung and bone cancer because when a cancer metastasizes remember it's still breast cancer so I wouldn't research I don't know that you need to continue to research that could just bring anxiety and I don't think that's helpful.
I think you continue to do the things that you're doing don't change anything if you have questions about supplementation make sure you either you don't set up a call with me or do another.
Cheek swab but you just first of all this question is did that so you don't need to do that again.
You just you are there's a lot of trust you're trusting in that in God whatever he has is going to you know for you is going to happen and that you can accept that if you're prayed that it doesn't reappear you're prayed ultimately that whatever happens that you're going to bring in glory that's the whole purpose of that so.
You just keep doing what you know to do it's not going to really help you to do any more research on breast cancer that you've already done so I would you know just caution you about that because that could be a springboard side familiar with homeopathic what is the first one I can see the label it is just search radiation.
holiopath that's a bad picture I apologize that's the only picture we have of our product it says radiation holiopathic drop that's what it says radiation holiopathic 12x dropper that's what the label says on it.
Okay that's the retake that picture there are questions alright well thank you guys for everything and is there a chance for recurrence when menopause comes no menopause would actually give you more protection so.
Because you're going to have decreased horrible production so no I don't think there's I think your risk of metastasis would go down slightly.
Alright happy new year everybody and I'm praying for you all and keep up the good work everybody's doing great and it's your questions and we'll talk in next week.